-Congratulations
on season three of the show.
-Thank you.
-You are a co-creator
of this show.
You're the showrunner
-I am.
-You're also in it.
There are scenes
where you have fights.
-Mm-hmm.
-There are fires.
There is nudity for yourself.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you ever regret,
once you start shooting it,
that you made yourself
do those things?
-I have no one to blame
but myself.
-Yeah.
-It's not just fire.
I lit myself on fire.
-Yeah.
-Which turns out is hot.
Yeah, that's, like, the --
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's like the key thing.
Everybody knows about fire.
-Yeah, I didn't.
I didn't know that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughing ]
-Especially when I say, "Can
you put more gasoline on me?"
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it gets really hot.
-And is it something like,
in the moment,
when you're actually
now on fire, do you think back
to the writers room
and the moment where it came up
and that you didn't
spike it then?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-That's when you think --
-Yeah.
There was one moment
I was actually on a snowmobile.
I did this jump on a snowmobile
into a river,
and then it goes
down in the river,
and these safety guys
come up to me and say,
"You know, the worst that's
gonna happen is, like,
the snowmobile, like,
rolls over on you
and you're pinned for
like a minute."
[ Laughter ]
"You know, but we'll be there.
We'll be there.
You can hold your breath
for a minute, right?"
-That is so much worse.
-Like, "No!"
-That's the worst
I thought could happen.
-I know.
-So, you co-created this show
with your wife, Sam Bee.
-Yes.
-Who's also very talented.
And you guys have kids.
And your kids have gotten
to be in episodes.
They don't play your children
in the show,
but they got to be
sort of extras.
Did they enjoy it?
-Well, my son
was, like, a featured actor.
-Oh, great!
-He plays young me on the show.
-Oh, fantastic!
-And my daughters were extras.
And I cut them.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Now, that's -- that's rough.
-I know!
-That's rough to begin with,
but then, with your son having a
plum role, that's really rough.
-And his paycheck is giant,
and theirs is nothing.
-[ Laughing ]
So how do you have to --
How do you tell your kids
they're cut?
-I was like, "Listen,
your scene was good."
-Yeah.
-"It wasn't great."
-Sure.
-But I gave them a scene --
I actually gave them a speaking
role in the next season.
That was season one I cut them.
Season two,
I gave them a speaking role.
And they were mad at me because
they liked their part better
in the first season.
-Oh, no!
-I'm like, "You get paid now!
You did it for free
as an extra."
-But they have taste.
-Now you get paid.
-They didn't care
for the new scene.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're obviously a writer.
You're an actor,
you're a comedian.
-Yes.
-Don't take this the wrong way.
I would not have guessed
that you began in modeling.
But you had
an early modeling career.
[ Laughter ]
-You're suggesting
that I'm an ugly child.
-No, I'm not at all!
-And you're not wrong!
-No.
How did modeling start for you?
-It started
like any child model.
My grandmother
owned a bridal boutique.
-There you go.
Perfect!
-And they're like,
"He can fit into a dress!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You actually sent some photos.
-I did.
-This is not bridal work.
-No.
This is my later work.
-Later work.
So this is pretty --
I mean, this is rad,
and that's the word
we used then
to describe that look.
-That's right.
-So, what is the brand here
that you're...?
-I don't -- Leather pants?
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
Well, there's a story.
Because show this one.
-Yeah, this one is fantastic.
-This one.
-I mean, that's fantastic.
-Well, it's not fantastic.
Because he was not a great
Michael Jackson impersonator.
-Okay.
-And I was really mad
that I had to just sit
on the bench and snap.
-Interesting.
-'Cause I could do the Moonwalk
way better than him.
And I didn't understand
at the time, as a child,
that maybe me
playing Michael Jackson
is probably not
the best casting choice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That if you were
opening a catalogue
and they went with you
instead of the other kid...
-Well, funny story.
I meet this kid again
on a casting call,
a go-see, I guess --
-[ Laughing ]
A go-see.
-That's a little modeling
lingo for you.
[ Laughter ]
So I meet him again,
and we're both up
for this department-store shoot.
It's called Robinsons, which is,
like, the Gimbels of Canada.
And we were up for the role
of Mr. T for a Halloween shoot.
And guess who got it.
-You booked Mr. T?!
-I booked Mr. T.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't clap for that!
-Yeah.
-I shouldn't have booked Mr. T!
[ Laughter ]
Because it was
a short-sleeve outfit,
and they didn't give me
a shirt to wear.
So it just a black mask
with white arms.
-That is, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-And a sign that said Mr. T
on the plastic outfit.
-That is rough.
That really speaks volumes
about how bad this guy
was at impressions.
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't even have to talk.
-Yeah.
-I know. Yeah.
-That's who I pity.
I pity him.
-You pity him!
I pity him!
-Thanks for being here.
Congrats on the show.
Always a pleasure
to see you, man.
Jason Jones, "The Detour,"
airs Tuesday nights on TBS.